well guys welcome to another episode of
the outdoor boys me and my little hombre
Nathan here we are going to make a
tomahawk throwing range that I guess
what we said I don't want to share what
the technical term is it we're gonna be
a big freakin wooden target and
tomahawks so that we can throw tomahawks
at big freakin wooden targets so that's
some fun yeah let's do it well as you
can tell I like to collect old axe heads
and restore them get them all cleaned up
put that handles on and in my journeys I
came across this beauty this tomahawk
was forged in southern Germany and it's
got the most beautiful makers mark sauna
I just love the look and feel of this
thing the only problem is it doesn't
need any restoration it has got a wicked
edge on it it is clean it is perfect I
just need to slap a handle on this thing
and that is not enough for an entire
video so I'm gonna do something else
something I've wanted to do for a while
I want to also have a target to throw
tomahawks at like not just a piece of
plywood I want it like a legit awesome
looking tomahawk throwing range so we're
gonna be making a target to throw
tomahawks at and to do that I need a
really big wood round and luckily I've
got a neighbor who's gonna hook me up
but these suckers are not light so I'm
gonna hook up the trailer and I've got
to come along and some other stuff we're
gonna see if we can't get one of these
wood rounds loaded up alright so here
the wood round and we need to pick a
really nice big one here this one's
looking really nice that's that's a
pretty good-looking one alright I think
that's the biggest one let me see if I
can even get that thing on its side
though gonna videotape me herniating a
disc here
Oh a snake no gardener snake oh it's a
pretty big piece of wood right there all
right that actually works cool go got a
couple of really nice wood rounds let's
go
[Music]
you know my problem is my chainsaw just
isn't quite long enough this isn't quite
the right tool for the job but I'm going
to go down through it and I'm going to
cut to at least the L on this side and
then I'm going to cut to the M on this
side that should do it
[Music]
[Music]
that's actually not too bad oh look at
that cool grain in there
well they sign up and set on me but I
got that wood round cut down to the size
I needed and yeah not too bad but I'm
gonna call it go eat some dinner and
I'll pick this up tomorrow all right now
I've got this piece of reclaimed lumber
from an old barn in Florida I thought it
was gonna be like some sort of hardwood
that's what I was told but I'm pretty
sure it's like pine or something it's a
fairly soft but it's been sitting on my
scrap pile for a long time it's so I
decided now is it's time to shine we're
gonna turn this into the base of our
tomahawk are you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well I think I'm just one piece of wood
shy of getting this done so keeping with
the theme of reclaimed wood I've got
this two-by-four from my old Forge stand
that I'm going to use and that's gonna
be the back brace
there we go look at that that target
looks pretty darn sweet so I'm gonna try
it out with my tactical tomahawk first
there we go all right guys
now we need to put a handle on this
gorgeous tomahawk and I have this piece
of wood here I think this is called
morado I'm not a hundred percent sure
but look at the grain on that and I've
got this chunk right here where it's got
a bit of
blondness right in there and I'm gonna
use this piece right here
give it a nice swirly pattern is gonna
be gorgeous
[Music]
by far the hardest part of this whole
process is trying to shape the wood to
fit exactly in the eye because you know
it's pretty round but it's not exactly
round and you're basically free handing
this you know trying to sit there and
eyeball it it's really easy to mess up
looks okay alright now I just need to go
ahead and shape the rest of the handle
so that's not quite
[Music]
well that was a lot of grinding but I
finally got it done it's pretty darn
round a little bit thicker on the bottom
than the top looks pretty good feels
great so now I got a sand this sucker
and I'm gonna get myself a chair there
we go it's all sanded what do you think
of that well this handle came out
awesome and I can't wait to get the
tomahawk head mounted on this thing but
I need to make a wedge first so we're
gonna go do that that's a little bit of
scrap wood here and I'm gonna use that
to make my wish
[Music]
[Applause]
there we go there's a little wedge I
wasn't a hundred percent sure what this
scrap wood was when I started making
this wedge but I'm pretty sure this is
purple heartwood so far so good
now we're gonna get some boiled linseed
oil here shiny the fun thing about
boiled linseed oil is it acts like a
lubricant when it's fresh but after it's
sat for a little while you get sticky
and then turns into an adhesive so it's
great for putting on axe heads because
it helps them slide right on and then
after it's been on for a little while it
starts to get sticky and it doesn't
makes it hard for them to slide off
there we go
[Music]
all right so now we're gonna drive this
little metal wedge in kind of at an
angle cracked a little bit but it's in
there
it is what it is now so guys here it is
here's the finished product yeah you
want to have it is that heavy Nathan
over here over here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there you go Oh Nathan did you have a
good time no this is a load of fun and
what are gorgeous tomahawk and I am so
pleased with this thing and it's a load
of fun to throw I like to target too I
think I'm gonna do some other things
I've got an idea for a ninja throwing
star video that I might use that that
target with but any rate thanks for
watching guys we hope you like this
video if you want to see more great axe
restoration and tool restoration videos
check the our playlist we have tons of
them and if you want to see more outdoor
boys videos click subscribe we put out
new videos every Saturday morning thanks
for watching guys